I have a question. And this is a sincere question. No hate, no nothing.
Cause the music say what you want, if you like it. That's great.
Certainly sounds nice. How come every time I open up anything, my phone,
my computer, my closet, or my zipper. I have to hear,
I have to read a headline about how, how amazing Lizzo looks.
Why do I have to, I always read that. That's my question to put out there.
Why do I have to always read
Lizzo was on the carpet of the Vietnam VMs and looked
and Slade. She's a queen. Look at how she killed her outfit.
And then I got to look and she's wearing literally a Hershey's bar.
She wore a dress that said Hershey's on it the other day. And everyone's like,
and she absolutely killed it. Hey dude.
No, she didn't. And that's just a regular free song.
I didn't put out on iTunes, dude.
You don't look good like that.
Why are we pretending that I know why I know why I know why we're saying it.
I know why we're saying it because she's overweight.
And because there's been so much fat shaming in the world that now we got to
backtrack and the pendulum swing too far the other way.
And now there has to be headlines every day about how sexy Lizzo
looks. But Hey, what about this? Her music.
What about that?
What about how your making it so looks are there
most important thing? What about that?
What about that? You superficial?
Who cares? If, who cares? How she looks then? Who cares?
How she looks? Right. If who cares?
That she's a little overweight then who cares?
How she looks?
Why do we have to keep talking about how bang?
And she looks, who cares?
Who gives a? I don't care what weight she is.
If she's happy and killing it onstage, what the do I care?
I don't give a, but, but every time,
Oh, she looks banging in that well.
Did she give you a tinfoil? People be like Lizzie, Lizzie showed up.
Boy, did she slay in some tinfoil? Hey,
now you look at the 10 men. It's embarrassing.
You're embarrassing yourself. Bloggers. I hope she knows.
And she's just taking the and you guys just don't even understand her levels.
Hey,
also she remember when she did the thing at the basketball game and she just
showed up with her out and everyone was like, she slayed her
was out. Dude. Her
was out. And we had to pretend like she slayed. Dude.
If my was out.
[Inaudible].
My whole, my, my in front of apartment blinds, just pivoting.
And then I open up and my opens up and I just go
New man on a Minnesota Vikings. She showed up wearing a,
her she's milk chocolate wrapper. Hey,
it didn't slay. It looked like chocolate. I mean,
dude, why do we pray? And she slayed, dude,
if Halle Berry showed up like that, you had a roaster.
Rightfully so.
It's hilarious. What this world has come to.
Oh, she got that chunk. Huh? Look at that.
Jesus.
Look at what everyone says pretty. I don't know. Oh,
what is she doing? Hey, you got grandma.
Hey, you got grandma. Anyone that does, that is a man.
These chicks, you know, there'll be on the phone. Her voice is the.
No man on the Venus on a biking's down, down the, down,
down, down, down. Anybody who does that in the middle of song. Um,
I hate when people say this, but I'm here for it.
Do it because you feel it's so dope down gown, go, go and get gum gum gong.
That's the, dude. I love it.
Put on a regular dress. Um, yeah,
I love it, dude. Uh, anyway,
I'll make an album and I'll show up in a Hershey's outfit.
Imagine if I made an album and my voice was the and I was killing it.
And then I showed up in a Hershey's outfit,
how they would drag me down gown, the gown.
Even if I did down gown, the gown, the gown, gown, gown,
new man on a Minnesota Vikings.
I love it. I love this movement. Whatever you do is right, girls,
whatever you do is right girls.
I had a guy, saw a guy with his, with a believer, all women shirt the other day.
And I literally just thought about how like my ex would lie to me a lot.
[inaudible] gown. No man on the Minnesota Vikings
dude, Hey man. Really believe all women. My girl cheated on me,
lots down [inaudible]
I canceled me. What the do I care? You know.